[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous demandons encore une
fois l'arrêt pur et simple des vols
intérieurs qui sont inutiles et
climaticides
[Musique]
combien comment à tous et la planète
terre donc s'allonger par terre en
quelques heures ce pas non plus trop de
monde un chemin
[Musique]
à l'heure de la sixième extinction de
masse et du chaos climatique
les de notre devoir de construire et de
vivre autrement
en fait on n'a plus le choix on n'a plus
foi que de que de désobéir vu la gravité
du problème
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
février 2020 dans un hangar de la région
parisienne
mango a aidé à préparer la prochaine
action du mouvement je vais installer sa
la banderole et puis épuisant salade au
lard et la banderole il va falloir que
quelqu'un fasse les oyés avec cette
action elles veulent s'attaquer à
l'industrie du btp et mettre en lumière
deux des quatre revendications du
mouvement la fin de la destruction des
écosystèmes et la neutralité carbone dès
2025 les stratégies qui attire en
quelques mois le mouvement est passé
d'une poignée de militants à plus de
17000 c'est vrai que ça faisait des
années que je faisais donc tout ce qu'on
appelle ses petits gestes du quotidien
passé zéro déchet adhérer à une amap
consommer local et un soir en fait j'ai
regardé en fine les suffragettes donc
rien à voir mais mais ce film m'a
beaucoup marqué parce que les femmes en
fait elle était moqué ont elles demandé
le droit de vote et c'est vrai que moi
ans quand je parle écologie souvent je
me sens un peu moqué stigmatiser alors
que pour moi c'est juste une évidence de
la problématique actuelle et une semaine
après j'ai entendu parler d'extinction
beau mais lyon et ça tellement résonné
en moi cette biologiste fait désormais
partie des anciennes et à plusieurs
actions de désobéissance civile à son
actif mais à extinction rébellion ou
ixair comme il l'appelle désobéir
ça s'apprend et que sa surveillance est
un mouvement mondial de désobéissance
civile non violente
aujourd'hui éric 50 en forme de nouveaux
militants aux techniques de
désobéissance civile la première c'est
dire la vérité sur la gravité et de
l'urgence de la situation thématiques
écologiques et moi je suis une ourse
je suis à auxerre depuis dix mois et
j'ai déjà fait par un d'action et je me
suis fait déloger par les filles quatre
fois déjà un vrai je suis raide
attention le port leçon du jour
comment ne pas être délogés par la
police il appelle à l'égaler du sol il
est complètement complètement flasque
complètement liquide même et là on peut
plus rien je suis 90 kg et moi du cochon
distribuées parmi ses futurs
désobéissants amaury 20 ans étudiant
dans le social c'est la première fois
qu'il s'engage dans un mouvement
et là vous baissez la tête et c'est de
nous déloger vous allez voir vous allez
avoir du mal parce qu'il ya très peu
d'extrémité je pense que ce soit au
peuple de faire bouger les choses
d'où la non violence parce que moi je
suis enfin je sais pas si je pars un peu
loin mais je suis contre le fait qu' on
fasse une énorme révolution qu'on casse
tout et c j'aimerais vraiment qu'ils se
passent un consensus que les gens
puissent discuter et qu'on puisse
discuter avec les dirigeants de
du pays la seule chose pourra ne sait
pas gérer c'est la non violence et
l'humour
donc c'est pour ça qu'on essaie de
m'aider de à l'oeuvre il ya un an je
travaillais sur un moteur très polluants
dans l'automobile et je pensais que la
technologie pourrait nous sauver encore
les d'ecully bride les véhicules
électriques à batterie les véhicules
électriques à hydrogène et puis j'ai eu
un déclic j'ai eu un déclic lors de la
marche du siècle le 16 mars 2019
lorsqu'un autre marcheur m'a parlé de
d'effondrement des populations
d'insectes
donc ça m'a donné une grande claque une
prise de conscience qui le pousse à
quitter son emploi et a changé
radicalement de vie depuis que j'ai
compris loge ans climatique et
écologique
donc je puis mois de mars 2009 a
longtemps il ya un an pour moi manger du
boeuf mais prendre l'avion c'était un
pas un problème quoi il faut tout
changer mais on peut pas tout sourire
même temps la viande ouais bah oui ce
soir des merguez
bon je sortais d'une saison tout en
s'armant régime magazine aujourd'hui il
consacre une grande partie de son temps
au mouvement et chercher un travail avec
du sens mais du coup on consomme plus
donc en fait pas l'évoquer qu'il
faudrait avoir été surtout fofana
sobriété quoi des petites deux choux
ouais les deux choses les quatre à elle
remet au goût du jour sera dynamique
la deux chevaux
allez
[Musique]
à la veille de l'action léa et manga
anime les derniers brief plusieurs
centaines de militants sont venus de
toute la france pour y participer ce
soir voilà vous allez recevoir un
message avec une heure et un lieu de
rendez vous mais le lieu de l'action lui
est toujours tenu secret et là on cite
vous allez diriger à en prendre à temps
avec votre référent vous attendrai un
signal partie des fuites mais que demain
et des forces de l'ordre partout ouais
ouais c'est c'est un risque et que on a
plusieurs actions qui qui n'ont pas pu
qui n'ont pas pu se faire
dernièrement notamment à cause de fuites
c'est c'est un peu le stress
donc vous allez débloquer une activité
économique et du coup à cela trois
risques principaux notamment et les
peines peuvent être lourdes en ont et
15000 euros pas d'avoir rassuré amaury
même si pour l'instant extinction
rébellion a rarement été poursuivis en
france entreprise en la bloquant au delà
d'être inquiet par rapport à ce qui va
se passer demain je suis inquiet du je
me pose d'autres questions sur la
société dans laquelle on vit
parce que je me dis que là on parle de
tous les risques juridiques et
finalement pour faire bouger les choses
pour pour faire bouger les choses pour
que la plaine sur laquelle on vit on la
protège ceux qui nous accueille on
risque des choses en fait pour ça et je
me dis mover donc tu vois trop ça va
être de protéger de prendre soin des
rebelles des autres l'organisation n'a
pas de chef
pour chaque action les militants
occupent des postes différents locker
est ce que vous voulez que je prenne la
paire de lunettes parce qu'ils vont se
faire un peu pour amaury ce sera un ange
gardien aussi leur demander est-ce que
je prends ton écharpe
parce qu'il ya des risques
d'étranglement
ok il ya des médiateurs qui sont en
train de parler hockey les médiateurs
sont lancés les médiateurs sont lancés
sur le site
au petit matin les grimpeurs découvre le
lieu de l'action deux cimenteries du 15e
arrondissement
il doit vite trouver un accès pour
déployer leurs banderoles
leucate faut ici on aimerait 2 ya le 3
milieu de trois par balles
[Musique]
amaury arrive lui aussi un peu perdu au
milieu des bétonnières alors en train de
chercher la zone où on doit se pointe
avec tout le reste de ce groupe à
l'autre bout du site
il retrouve enfin son groupe bon on va
sortir les drapeaux
non non non il ya du monde
salaire salaire bien organisé donc non
là ça va mieux déjà en action les
militants bloquent chaque contrée à
l'aide de ces gros sont remplies de
détour on va se mettre tous comme ça et
on peut comme ça se poser sur son
camarade d'air normalement c'est la
distance est fait pour
on est en train de ces arbres qui en
fait on se bloque le droit dans le bloc
de béton pour que l'on puisse pas nous
déloger
voici revenus d alger qu'il a cassé le
bras la logistique est complexe pour
mangwa c'est un peu la course entre
toutes les choses à gérer
il manque une laisse deviner on est
vraiment bien sur mon blog de sites donc
ici c'est le premier jaune de produits
en béton à paris en fait qui ravitaille
jusqu'à 15 sentiers par jour donc en
fait on a peut-être bloqué 15 chantiers
en même temps et ici en fait toute la
zone de la marche où on voit le granulat
et le sable qui sont les ressources
justement première et c'est ce qu'on
essaye de dénoncer avec 7 / exploitation
du sable les bétonnières sont repeintes
devant les ouvriers un peu perplexe
je sais ensemble ouvriers eric est
justement chargé de dialoguer avec eux
pour cette action il a des prises de
parole on va vous expliquer pourquoi on
fait ça aujourd'hui
ça doit vous intéressez ça va se passer
là bas le dialogue n'est pas toujours
évident je suis au téléphone et éric
n'est pas le seul à devoir gérer des
situations délicates
je veux juste faire marche arrière puis
sur la cage il ya la pléthore des dents
oui et je vais mettre des noms il avait
deux enfants
oui mais là il ya beaucoup de monde
croyait c'est un peu embêtant
oui je comprends bien mais après si le
béton et reste collé dans toute la
journée d'autres amis notamment pour des
moments qui sont délicats parce que les
gars sur place ils sont super cool et ça
se passe très bien avec eux donc c'est
compliqué humainement c'est toujours dur
voilà la violence qu'on leur fait on en
est conscient mais mon grand les avions
ce qu'on défend qu'on dénonce la
dépolitisation du vivant chaque semaine
on détruit les cars de crs de paris dans
le monde hommes en béton relève étonnant
on est dans sa voie là
pour cette action les forces de l'ordre
n'interviendront pas apprécié et heures
d'occupation
les activistes quittent le site dans le
calme amaury n'a pas repris les actions
après sa première expérience en février
faute de temps il a un peu laissé de
côté extinction rébellion j'ai 99
quantification faudra y aller tous les
jours qu est-ce que c'est comme du
boulot quand on sait que cesse cette
action qui nous aura pris beaucoup de
temps d'énergie d'organisation de tout
ça eh ben elle n'a pas d'impact parce
que derrière ils vont continuer à faire
leur industrie du bâtiment allait aller
casser les écosystèmes dans les océans
pour récupérer du sable c'est prévu
découragement en fait eric mangwa et léa
ont aussi traversé des moments de doute
mais il reste convaincu de l'efficacité
de leur action
le livre moi je pense que c'est une
victoire rien que d'avoir pu faire
parler de ce sujet et ça veut absolument
pas dire que nous enfin je pense que
nous ça c'est la première étape
je pense qu'il ya vraiment le
l'ambition de continuer jusqu'à ce
qu'ils aient une mesure qui passe
eric ne regrette pas non plus ses choix
et prépare déjà une nouvelle action sur
l'industrie automobile
je croyais qu'on allait faire la prise
de la bastille en une journée et que
tout allait changer le lendemain bon et
puis c'est pas si simple que ça mais bon
on est toujours là toujours plus
nombreux même si le chemin est plus long
que prévu
ils sont déterminés à ne pas être des
cassandre et à se faire entendre sur
l'urgence climatique
[Musique]